[Music]
okay serious time George
Floyd mmm have you guys heard yeah it's
[__] up I didn't want to watch I
didn't watch it because I already knew
yeah but then I was like I'm not gonna
watch this [__] now I had to watch it
his name is George Floyd yeah
don't forget his face yeah so I mean
this is freaking crazy guys cuz just the
last time we all came together and
filmed it was um our brie and it's just
like are you [__] kidding me man like
this is this is the part that trips me
out is so a lot of law enforcement
already know how sensitive of a time it
is right I'm like why wouldn't you take
extra care extra precaution so that we
don't increase the tensions across the
nation cuz right now anything that
happens in one city will affect the
tensions in the other especially when
you know everybody has their phones out
you know what I think I have a whole
theory about this I think it's the thin
blue line you protect blue yeah I think
they feel like immunity to anything yeah
the blue van
they can't like it cuz look when they
put the uniform on it doesn't matter if
you're white black or brown it's all the
blue I want okay we'll go through the
story first but my whole my entire thing
on this is that it's outrageous that the
other cops didn't do anything right yes
that's when I saw that one of them was
in two of them and the moms aw I think
it's a lot of Hmong in Minneapolis yeah
I just made an assumption but I don't
even know what that means
is it so yeah it's an it's not very
known yeah yeah no no so I pointed out
the Hmong situation because most moms
come from a low-income neighborhood and
they should sympathize and understand
the [__] reality of violence from
police so they're not like quote-unquote
privileged Asians that come from rich
ass [__] neighborhoods right so I'm
just like the blue veil is at it again
yeah it's kind of [__] up blue
protective blue it's like a gang man it
is it's a fraternity throw
very very very none of those guys ever
get in trouble unless there's no huge
cookie Freddie great no indictments okay
good yeah really yeah no indictments mm
okay there's a stat out there it was
like 99 percent of police involved
shootings and problems and everything
that happened where someone died
not investigated went free whatever and
only like one small incident like from
internal investigation they actually
penalizing it was in like 2000 and
[__] nine though okay also real
quickly
like what doges said the the FBI if they
come at you with charges it's like you
have a 95 percent chance of being
indicted and going to jail
like like the ADA so our justice system
is supposed to be weighted in my oh you
could win all the [__] but like how come
the feds have that much power over
people where it's that [__] high
like you're going away if they start
investigating yeah it's investigating
the cops no I'm saying if they see you
or anybody individually business people
whatever the [__] with the internal
affairs yeah I don't even know I don't
even know but but but we know that the
system isn't working because of [__]
like Freddie gray but going there's a
video in case you've been living under a
rock that has been gone I had gone in
there I didn't watch it because I was
gonna hurt my feelings I knew we're
gonna watch it here I know
okay so let's watch it listen we're
gonna we're gonna play this so very
disturbing so skip ahead if you don't
want to see this yeah I've seen it I'll
pass especially since you know what
happens at the end and it starts with
the Asian car yeah looking down nothing
to do before I play this the cop side of
the story is that they were responding
to a call about forgery and they said
that the suspect was waiting in his car
and apparently was gonna be dangerous
and so they tried to apprehend him and
then the cops are saying that George was
resisting arrest and that is the reason
why they've detained him in this way but
there hadn't been multiple witnesses
coming forward saying like there was no
resisting at all yeah it was video that
you [__] already he's [__] cop cop
yeah it's still
what's resisting exactly you're gonna
see in this video he says multiple times
I can't breathe it's so [__] sounds
familiar it's exactly so [__] up
sounds like something that happened
within less than five years ago it was
2015 singing everything hurts water
you need water
well they have them cuffed at this point
right you know you get subdued no so why
don't they just pick a mother from
another angle with you other guys are
sitting on top fragrant a table somehow
remember more yeah
this is [__] this is this is this is
our Rodney King mm-hmm
there's so many though like holy [__]
why is it every other week well here's I
grew up in a more [__] up neighborhood
and it's literally now just being taped
like it's been happening mm-hmm like
that's what the rest of America doesn't
understand and know that I like this
kind of [__] is happening all the [__]
since and it was actually worse in the
80s and 90s that's what people don't get
well it was so pervasive in the 70s 80s
and 90s right that that people in the
news media even glossed over a lot of
[__] and I mean Hilary used to call the
black youth super predators and that was
violence Prince's like it was yeah and
Joe Biden said he didn't want his kids
raised in a racial jungle or whatever
the [__] like like there's a lot of this
[__] going on man and it's like now with
the internet now with people grabbing
phones and everything cameras and
everything now you see it but it's been
something that's been happening in the
States everyone now is like oh my god
there's so much racism happening it's
like actually it's just being recorded
oh great so it's not that it it's not
that it's like out of nowhere oh my god
this is happening it's more like what
the [__] we're shining a light on this
even more and more and more and more and
we're getting like at like you know as
this
everyone's just [__] fed the [__] up
to the point where now there's so many
riots happening looting even like in
Chicago and in LA and Memphis there are
protests happening literally as we speak
right now the helplessness
that's what happens Brian King right it
wasn't just random it was helplessness
like when you feel like the system is
not working at all we're to the point
where people who can murder people go on
fired and not indicted or fired and not
arrested then yeah you're gonna feel
like I [__] the [__] I'm gonna threaten
everything you're [__] protecting and
everything it's like anything that makes
your [__] money pockets your pockets
money then I'm gonna [__] threaten
that's how you [__] but didn't you
guys hear I heard this week that Wall
Street just hit a new all-time high
while unemployment is it just hit an
all-time high ah so [__] off with this
[__] where we all have to pretend like
everything's going fine and like what
just happened isn't [__] nuts right
right and then at the same time you have
like the Karen's of Central Park
thinking that they can just call up the
cops and like lie about like making a
false report well they don't know how
dangerous it is to actually call a cop
on a minority because people get handled
much much differently and they just
think oh well fine you know they're
gonna I'm gonna get to bully him by
using the cops against them not knowing
that you're actually helping people
commit murder without even knowing and
blue protects blue from all day streets
to the top of the [__] FBI and
Justice Department and judges and all
this [__] we've seen it before like if
you look at Freddie gray right what did
they say they said that Freddie gray cuz
because only because we don't have
enough about this case we saw the video
it's horrifico Ruiz defending it but we
don't have every single detail we have
every single detail about the Freddie
gray great case I can't breathe the
original one yeah okay so what happened
with that right so apparently Freddie
gray was was selling cigarettes that
were not being taxed and so the cops
were confronting him about that [__] and
he literally lost his life because he
was selling allegedly selling cigarettes
right he was never tried for that like
we all have civil rights he should be
proven in a court of law as having done
that and found guilty or whatever before
he gets [__] penalized but instead he
gets killed on the street for it and if
you watch the video of Freddie gray
he gets tackled by [__] nine cops
yeah and he was children right and he
was [__] he was F&E he's just
sticking up for assault like y'all I'm
not doing anything wrong that's fine I'm
totally fine if any he's just gesturing
like this like Conan O'Brien on
late-night yeah cuz yeah and then you
see that Karen's going [__] you cops I
have a [__] brett and they're going
at their easy like they got the biggest
ball on their guns and [__] like calling
the cops like [__] [__] and I
don't know how many other things and
think the cops are just like they're
like like come on man so part of this
slide right so Freddie great how did it
slide the Justice Department says that
this unleashed a crazy perfect storm
chain reaction that led to an asthma
attack slash heart attack and he died
but we all know why he got choked out
you could look at it yeah but they said
that we wouldn't be able to defend this
in a court of law and we would not be
able to make a case they make cases all
the time against all kinds about George
here where they're like appeared to be
suffering medical distress so if I am
somebody in this community hell I'm me
and I'm I don't believe in justice right
now I just don't I think that everyone
in there should be [__] kicked out
yeah well you did fire the four police
officers but people are demanding we
should be charging mother thank you I
saw video of 74 cops defending this
dudes home cuz protesters came in Oh
make sure that least of the cop with the
knee on the actually turned out to not
be oh yeah yeah go wide again yeah I
wasn't sure about that I was like it
could be a no what they went up to is
the police station right and they were
they were protesting their video yeah
crazy I have that video of the protest
and so there's a lot of protesting
happening right now it's pretty it's
pretty much
you're smashing car windows
what does that
skateboards and cops all know I mean
this is obviously the season right
they're not justice this [__] yeah
here's what happens next right so
conservative media is gonna say that
these people are animals and that you
should not do this kind of thing and
what's crazy about what they're doing
really is they're just reacting to this
situation because they feel completely
[__] faut people get pushed to the
edge they're gonna they have nothing to
lose anymore
I mean it's frustrating when the life is
a lie and you feel like how many
hashtags how many tweets how many
[__] social media posts kind of do
the protests that do nothing right it
does nothing because they're not gonna
get indicted they're not gonna be
investigated they're gonna hope that
everybody forgets so that's why people
have to react to this level of extremism
and this is why my problem is blue
protects blue right so this is what I
was gonna have to begin a video and
government protects government well yeah
if you're a cop and you know this your
partner is like this and he's gonna be
this [__] tough on people or whatever
he thinks is tough and he's gonna choke
somebody out to the point of death like
this isn't new to you this is something
that just randomly happens
oh he just suddenly did this in a moment
with a guy who's cuffed on the ground
he's obviously [__] angry at
something else that's going on you seen
another racial attack where are the good
guys who are gonna [__] whistle blow
on their partners and on their [__]
well there have been a lot of cops
coming forward and saying like [__] this
no doubt [__] this like I will have a in
internal affairs where are they
as far as reporting this [__] internally
and stopping it internally like that's
what's outrageous well blue protects
blue to the [__] top there's there's
actually several people who leave the
department and they whistle blow and
they talk about their whole experience
and they do try and they get destroyed
yeah Donnie Brasco I mean dude that
happens all the [__] time that that's
what's oh yeah who was the guy that was
here in LA like Chris Dorner yeah the
guy that was guy hit in the cabinet like
fed up already because like he had faced
a lot of racial [__] and like he tried
to do as Chris Dorner yells Chris Dorner
got the ramparts game yeah yeah yeah no
part was way like it was Melanie no
rampart scandal was when the police were
caught planting drugs on young black
right you
was a guy he I think he kind of
barricaded a house and he wanted to like
whistle had like a manifesto he wrote
out trying to enter out all this dirty
stuff about the LAPD and then and then
he got surrounded they ended up you know
yeah so Rodney King happened rampart
happened like all this like all these
incidents have have been pretty great
happen all these things have happened
and people are like you know I don't
think that justice exists and I'm yeah
and so media will come out condemning
them and calling them
rioters calling them terrorists calling
them all kinds of different names so
people get scared of what's happening
and then they put the focus on them
acting like animals rather than really
where the real problem is is the
corruption and the police force in
government and hiding and excusing this
kind of behavior and the Justice
Department it's like when you are
arguing with your girlfriend so much and
you can only say so much and then it's
like and then you [__] you to punch a
wall oh [__] he's serious yeah
you don't think you can suppress my
words can only do so much and you're
like [__] I need to throw something
right and I feel like that's like the
level of frustration everybody's like
how much can I say that does nothing and
now I need to [__] show you something
that shows you how like this angry I
turn back the clock a week ago
conservatives were like yo I
it's outrageous I can't go outside I
can't do all this [__] like [__] I
have my rights I have my [__] I want
to bring my gun on the street all this
[__] but like then the same people are
bitching about this stuff yeah so how
dare you go out and protest in big
groups about what about this [__] yeah
the same [__] exact thing but people
don't understand both sides of this [__]
like you have to understand both sides
right really no for me they're playing
us against each other back that's the
whole thing is like I'll have ideas and
views that might lean left and right but
then the point is those are just ideas
they're not identities and that's where
the problem comes I think people
identify with either side and they say
[__] you guys [__] this group [__] this
culture these cultures are always this
way or whatever right and then what ends
up happening is now you don't see each
other as Americans you see each other as
like they're in my territory while they
all expand wealth of the top right six
trillion dollars go divide and conquer
up yep divide them
[__] [__] thank you to my Japanese
Overlord he tells me he tells me what to
say and I listen in
[Music]